peu plus
[Musique]
la séparation entre les deux berlin se
fait plus dur chaque jour par des gestes
multiples la population de berlin-ouest
manifeste sans répit sa colère tout le
long de la barrière qu'elle nomme le mur
de la honte
depuis quelques jours le gouvernement de
poing coffre est de nouveau renforcé
cette barrière qui interdit totalement
l'accès de la porte de brandebourg un
véritable mur de béton haut de deux
mètres doublé par des chevaux de frise
qui rappelle la ligne siegfried sépare
les deux berlin prétexte officiel
accroître la sécurité de berlin s
[Musique]
c ces mesures ont suscité une
manifestation de 15 mille jeunes
berlinois de l'ouest qui à la lumière
des torches ont organisé une marche de
protestation contre le mur
[Musique]
voici 17 ans dans strasbourg libérer le
général de gaulle était allé célébrer au
milieu de l'armée française remise au
combat l'action héroïque qui avait sauvé
la capitale alsacienne
avec leclerc et avec delattre dans cette
cathédrale que le serment de koufra fixé
comme le but même de la résurrection de
l'armée française il avait entendu le
thé des hommes de la victoire
[Musique]
et puis 17 ans ont passé le clair et de
lattes ont disparu et le général de
gaulle est revenu à strasbourg où il
avait donné rendez vous à trois mille
officiers et sous-officiers venus de
tous les corps d'une armée que les
avatars du temps ont troublé
on peut s'expliquer
et moi même où le premier
que dans l'esprit et dans le coeur
de certains soldats
se soit fait jour
d'autres souhaits
et même l'illusion
qu'à force de vouloir
on pourrait faire en ce sens que les
choses soient
ce que l'on désire
et le contraire de ce qu elles sont mais
dès lors que l'état et la nation ont
choisi leur chemin
le devoir militaire est fixé une fois
pour toutes
hors de ces règles il n'y à une paix
qu'à voir
que des soldats perdus
des soldats perdus ils ne peuvent pas
laid il n'y a qu'à voir défiler dans le
brouillard de strasbourg cette armée
rénové pour sentir selon les paroles du
chef de l'état la confiance de la france
en elle-même et en son armée
[Musique]
est-ce pour y chercher des leçons des
exemples des raisons de vivre et
d'espérer le monde moderne se retourne
avec tant de curiosité sur le passé
jamais en effet on a fait telle place à
l'archéologie aujourd'hui encore près de
mexico une mission est en train de
mettre à jour une pyramide aztèque
vieille de huit cents ans dans un site
jusqu'ici inexplorés et où les
possibilités de découvertes sont
considérables
cette pyramide de taille modeste n'a
évidemment rien de commun avec les
normes pyramide du soleil haute de 73 m
gueye d'environ 3000 ans et qui est sans
contredit le plus remarquable des 11000
monument aujourd'hui classé de l'étrange
civilisation aztèque
[Musique]
du plus lointain passé aux techniques
d'aujourd'hui voici la technique la plus
moderne que les chemins de fer français
utilisent pour le renouvellement de leur
voix écoutez bien on pense sur le
remblai une voie provisoire composé de
tronçons de 18 mètres à l'écartement
normal
grâce à cette voie provisoire on dépose
sur les traverses à l'extérieur des fils
de rails de 300 mètres qui constitueront
la voix définitive cette voie plus
larges que la normale est simplement
posé sans être fixé et voici l'opération
technique qui se réalise sous vos yeux à
l'aide de quatre chariots un chariot
réduit l'écartement des rails de la voie
provisoire laissant l'emplacement libre
pour la future voie ferrée
[Musique]
les fils de rails de 300 mètres
composant cette future loi sont alors
amenés à l'écartement normale est
définitif et tout en reculant le train
ramasse la voie provisoire désormais
sans objet ainsi la sncf poursuit-elle
la modernisation de toutes ces
installations
[Musique]
le boeuf et le boucher c'est un titre
qui fait songer à une fable or c'est un
drame est un problème le gouvernement
ayant devant la hausse du bifteck décidé
la taxation de la viande les bouchers
ont décidé de ne plus vendre de boeuf
s'est réduite à ces éléments de base la
question du jour la fièvre monte à la
police d'intervenir aux abattoirs de la
villette qui sont comme le thermomètre
de la boucherie et de l'élevage et les
bouchers se refusait à s'approvisionner
en boeufs
autre problème walt les entrepôts
frigorifiques comptait déjà soixante
mille tonnes de viande l'état devrait-il
se charger d'un surcroît de marchandises
que les bouchers se refusait à écouler
mais ce débat cache l'essentiel entre la
viande morte et la bête vivante pourquoi
cet écart qui multiplie par cinq le prix
d'achat sur pied
nous avons demandé à un éleveur ce qu'il
pense de ce mystère
je n'ai pas complètement je vais me
mettre sur pied deux sens capable mais
maman bio servis dans 370 francs le kilo
de viande dans sa cage je m'étonne après
soeur que le consommateur ne puisse pas
trouver l'idée c'est qu'à moins de 12 à
15 ans 100 kg alors que préconisez vous
moi je trouve qu'il n'ya pas besoin de
quatre ou cinq personnes à temps quand
ça m'a tellement je préfèrerais vendre
leurs bêtes à une seule organisation il
s'occuperait de l'abattage est dans
l'opposition le fait est que entre
l'éleveur et le push et on compte
quelques intermédiaires le petit
ramasseur qui vend à un confrère plus
étoffé qui vend à un chevillard de la
villette qui vend un grossiste qui
vendra au boucher
autre chose encore la vétusté des
installations et l'inorganisation de
l'industrie les sous-produits une
employée du temps de la marchandise est
de l'argent perdu
seul ici la réorganisation du circuit la
révolution clés du circuit court
l'abattoir industriel en plein pays
d'élevage résoudrait la question chemin
direct qui mène sans intermédiaire du
producteur aux bouchers ou aux
consommateurs traitement à la chaîne
sans perte d'où un prix de revient plus
bas
ces abattoirs en outre récupère et
utilise scientifiquement les déchets
rendant l'opération plus rentable
puisqu'elle supprime une charge
jusqu'ici supporté par le rosbif
dans les premiers supermarchés déjà chez
déboucher un jour la ménagère trouvera
sous cellophane la viande de notre
circuit court ce sera
l'approvisionnement moderne d'un pays
moderne qui dans ce domaine de la viande
en est resté à henri iv mais revenons à
la question du jour à cette bataille du
bifteck selon les derniers
développements elle semble évoluer vers
l'apaisement à la salle wagram les
bouchers parisiens dont le leader
monsieur drucbert a déjà souvent fait
parler de lui ont tenu une réunion
houleuse mais la raison peut quelquefois
se faire entendre même débouché en
colère et il semble avoir fait un pas et
même peut-être index
à
on attendait avec curiosité la rencontre
du stade français et de l'équipe
sedanaise leader inattendu du
championnat
et malgré le mauvais temps 25000
parisien était au parc des princes tout
de suite on peut constater que le stade
joué l'un de ses meilleurs matches c'est
lui en effet qui marquait coup sur coup
les deux premiers but à la 25e et à la
28e minute
sedan allait-il baisser les bras devant
la malchance non les ardennes et au
contraire aller maintenant serait dire
et ont entamé une contre attaque
méritoire qui grâce au tandem breni
michel aller avant la mi-temps réduire
la marque
cinq minutes après la mi temps sedan
encouragé par son premier succès marqué
par faustino le second but égalisateur
[Applaudissements]
on pouvait croire que les sedanais remis
en selle allaient poursuivre leur
avantage le stade ne leur permit pas son
de mista qu omar kane
dès lors la partie était jouée l'énergie
du désespoir manifesté par sedan 9e du
baloir qu'une nouvelle déception trois
minutes avant la fin bourbotte marquer
un quatrième but pour le stade
[Musique]